you know what I'ma load up I'm just  gonna pick my load out right here I  don't think that's gonna help your  stomach no it's isn't this what caused  it that's the thing you don't know what  caused it no it was like a temporary  food poisoning that's rough man I don't  want to be I mean I've already been  Graphics so you might as well just go  all the way it was just straight  bile coming out my ass  I knew I was dying when I was wiping and  like why does it look like I just like  dumped like you know like rubbing  alcohol onto a napkin like what did I  drink Mountain Dew yeah okay why is it  glowing yeah it's always scary when you  start like throwing up bile because  you're like yeah I'm at the end I'm at  the toxic sludge you know that's like  brain fluid or something yeah yeah after  five after bile there's only there's  only blood yeah that's all that's left  what other fluid is there your body's  just like well yeah yeah